hi i'm christopher hine today we're
going to be talking about the dodi waza
so this wraps up our series on kumiuchi
which are the struggle methods found in
aikido and the way i approach aikido
those struggle methods are
non-ideal things right and i think uh
mostly that's what we see in aikido are
the kumiuchi because it's easy to see
that and it's a lot harder to talk about
situational awareness and attention and
all the other things that come into
aikido
whereas the techniques are just kind of
easy to see so the kumiuchi series is
the struggle method so dodi was is the
last one this is not going to be a
really long video i'm going to basically
explain the dodiwaza why we have the the
grabs and things that we have and so
dory specifically means to to seize
something so why we have the dodi waza
we have
should be a really short simple video
and this will complete our section on
the kumiuchi josh let's go to work
all right so let's talk about the
dodiwaza this wraps up our uchi series
which is our struggle method series
i think the dodori or sorry the the
doriwaza as a whole are very telling the
dodori for me really helped me kind of
put the last pieces of iketer together
and the tedori kind of got me started so
in lots of ways the dodiwaza bookends
them and let me explain what i'm saying
i break up doriwaza into two sections
one is tet dory those are the hand grabs
and the other is dory those are the body
grabs so the hand grabs are these and
the body grabs are anything that's on
the body itself right so whether that's
kata rio kata mune eri ere
so and those names are just really
simple names moonet means chest edit
means collar right so this actually
should be
ushiro because it's the collar from
behind
your hands are just whether your hands
are
straight across from your hand or
diagonal across from your hand right now
why those exist is really important
because when you look at those grabs and
you say hey here's the core attacks we
have in aikido other martial arts that
are grappling martial arts look at that
and say those are ridiculous because
there's nothing to those right so
meaning that while you might see someone
grab a wrist in wrestling that wrist is
a transitory position to get into a
deeper hold and the deeper hole holds
them better so one of the problems you
have with any of the the tet dory the
hand grabs is that they do a bad job of
controlling the body so if i grab josh's
hand everything else in josh's body can
move around right now if i'm grappling
with that that means he can get a lot of
power behind by moving the rest of his
body to escape this hand hold right so
it's really a poor hold and in grappling
styles you'll see them using hip grabs
body grabs leg grabs because by
controlling the core of his body then
i'm able to control him better now you
might think that something like a moon
at dory then is a better hold because
it's holding the core of his body but
the problem with munidori is it's such a
small grab right so that's nothing
compared to me putting my whole body in
here and grabbing with the entirety of
my body now for the hand grabs we can
instantly understand them by putting a
knife in josh's hand so if there's a
knife in josh's hand like actually let
me switch to the other hand and i come
in here and i grab josh's body like this
you see i'm not controlling that hand so
even even if i get a bear hug he's still
got a little bit of room in there right
so and that's room i don't want so all
things will begin with controlling that
weapon hand so that's how i'm going to
begin is by controlling that weapon hand
right here and then will the will the
crease and hold well will the hold
increase it will if we're doing some jiu
jitsu style work right i would crease
but i always have to be holding on to
this hand now this in the beginning when
i thought aikido was a kind of japanese
jitsu
forced me to kind of make a set of
clinches that were our additional grabs
that we had and i'll put a picture of
them on here so you can see them but i
created a set of additional clinches
that you need and those clinches are
just how you would hold the hand while
moving around the body so when something
like a shiro kubashima when you look at
this kind of graph oh this suddenly
starts to make sense as to why you're
holding their hand while you're choking
them because i have to check this weapon
now there's a set of those that go all
the way around the body and i outline
them and when i was looking at aikido's
jitsu system that was one of the real
confusing things to me because i was
like it it has to have these kinds of
holds and the fact that no aikido style
talks about holds that look like this or
not any style that i discovered
then it's silly that these don't exist
but when you look at it as the guys with
the weapon the emphasis becomes on josh
being able to clear this as soon as
possible right so if it gets into a
deeper hold well that's beyond the
martial art of aikido but at this
beginning hold now he needs to find some
way to escape and then get his weapon
back in the game so it's very important
for him that he master how to deal with
hand grabs now for body grabs look this
body grab doesn't secure me at all or me
from him stabbing me at all right so why
would i use this now this makes sense
because i'm stopping the weapon but this
kind of grab or this kind of grab or
this kind of grab don't make any sense
now i have two answers for this one
answer for this is as you would see in
budo rinshu the first
kind of collected work by yoshiba it's
not exactly that he wrote it although he
did look it over and say hey yeah this
is the stuff we want in that you see
lots of people grabbing and then coming
in with an attack right so you see these
kinds of situations and you can
understand how this could have some
implication
while this is something useful when you
get into jitsu stuff you do want to
understand how those work and and those
are part of the ikea training we do here
those are not really what we're looking
at nikita what we're looking at aikido
is even though he's stabbing me if i can
hold on to him long enough to slow him
down while he's trying to get away from
someone else right he's stabbing me
doesn't matter because i'm holding him
long enough for my buddy to come in and
get him so he has to master those quick
body clears right so that's why we have
these kind of grabs and those are the
very things i would quickly snag if
we're moving around right so if i'm
running after josh and you're gonna have
to run slow if i'm running after josh
and josh is moving away there and i
reach my hand out you can see i get cop
the door right so if i just try to grab
his sleeve here i get caught the dory
okay if josh has turned around for me
and running i have to grab his collar up
here there's eredori right so there's
where editorial comes from right if josh
is moving to the side and my hand sneaks
out bang and i grab him munedori here
okay if he shoots out to the side and i
miss the moonadore i grab here and
that's going to force me to come around
and get a deeper control here and who
share a real cathedral right from usher
real cop the dory if he wanted to stab
me back here right so he starts stabbing
me and i can't can't quite save myself
i'm going to want to check that hand and
we get this top door with a not as great
grab here so what would i do i'd
probably increase that grab to something
like this okay if he were to switch
hands here and come back to get me i can
check this back side so we can see by
putting a weapon in his hand and
thinking of a context where we're moving
around as fast as possible these are the
essential holds we have to learn to
escape if the holds get deeper than this
it's a system beyond aikido just like
boxing doesn't look at headlocks or
double leg takedowns because that's
beyond that system if you want to learn
something more than that go study
another system so if you want to get
good at jiu-jitsu study jiu-jitsu it's a
perfectly good system that's there to
use whether japanese or modern style
jiu-jitsu it's a perfectly good system
but aikido's teaching you to stay
autonomous as long as possible so that's
why we have the holds that we have now
also included in my approach to
doriwaza is weapon taking the weapon
taking also is a little bit of a weird
caveat though because we're going to use
the previous kumiuchi to do the weapon
taking there's not a lot of special
extra moves we're either going to use
some part of the nagewaza or some part
of the kyowasa in order to escape so
meaning if i take this out of josh's
hand now strictly speaking that's adored
he was that's a tanto dudi i took the
knife from josh i seized the knife from
josh but i used enikyo to do that right
so so we do include the actual specific
weapon taking in doriwaza but it's a
little bit of a trick because all that
exists in the other parts of kumiuchi
all the tools we're going to use to do
that so this is an overview of how i
look at doriwaza and why the dodiwaza
has to exist in aikido and why it's
contextually appropriate to the context
i put on aikido
that i think is its natural context uh
anyways that is it for this kumiuchi
series where you can get some different
stuff after this or keep making weekly
videos for you guys appreciate your
patronage thank you very much this is
joshua teehee maya solano mcdaniel is
behind the camera and i'm christopher
hine thank you for watching
[Music]